Born to an Italian contessa and a British army officer in 1922,...
...Christopher Lee spent five years in the Royal Air Force...
...before pursuing a career in acting.
After a series of small roles, it was this one which marked him out.
His role as Dracula in the 1958 film the "Horror of Dracula"...
...brought him to worldwide attention.
Lee went on to make his name playing villains...
...once admitting they were more interesting characters to play.
Sir Christopher Lee has said he was not a fan of red carpet appearances,...
...preferring his audiences to be drawn into his roles on-screen.
His legacy will live on in his legions of fans across the generations...
...who've witnessed a legend of film.